what's more important to you love or
money
money [ __ ] you know
with money i can buy some love if you
understand me yeah
all right ap yeah yeah ap uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
you know i'm from memphis i grew up in
north missouri
north memphis and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young yeah yeah
until you know probably until like seven
yeah they were separated so my mom
she raised me and two of my brother and
how would you describe your childhood
well you know i mean describe it as good
you know never in the hand on wheels and
now we just
you know just did everything you know we
supposed to do for school or whatever
you know i try to try to be sticking so
i you know
selling drugs and you know
got into a situation my mom found out
you know it went from there so after
that
i was like 11 years old man
they they get me off the porch so yeah
i'll just continue on
you know just trying to making me falls
you know
stick sail throughs or whatever and then
i'm still going to school until i
just completely stopped going to school
and she squeaked this out
squeaking with grinding and you know
just making money putting up buying cars
and just sensible
etc and just you know
sorry just you know this is how i went
there i had my first child i was 15.
so you know it was just once again
like how far did you go in school i went
i went to uh ninth grade was the house
was
that's great i started going to school
tonight
you started working as a pimp at what
point
well i'm gonna say this hell you know uh
it ain't that penalty
i just didn't know i didn't put it into
perspective until i oh no you know what
pen
was you're saying what i'm saying did
you have it in your family or did you
have friends that showed you the ropes
yeah you know it was basically you know
a lot of
older guys that was around my
neighborhood or whatever
you know they were doing anything and
i'm just sitting back looking as a young
you know young people i'm watching like
and they got nice cars and
plenty of jewelry and [ __ ] money on my
channel you know
sneak up on a little come up and that's
how i went
what was the hardest part of learning
the hardest part what was the hardest
part of learning how to do this
saving money yeah you know it's just
like
you know if you know saying when you pay
me you know
permits people putting in my pocket you
understand what i'm saying so
what they're being said you know it's
just they gotta you know you gotta
you gotta eat it i mean females have
it's how he'll say
well you haven't ain't got no choices i
said well business materials you do have
a choice you get inline or get out of
line
so you know that's just what's going on
and then
any angry two minutes you know you don't
have
too many you can have a one turn one
chance not to pay my money you know
and then i'll just let you go you know
like the money disappeared that's why
i'm gonna make you
disappear you know it's just how to go
so your style is what
there's gorilla pimps there's finesse
pimps
there's all kinds of different styles
how would you describe yourself
what kind of any kind of pill you don't
say
all kind of feeling [ __ ] you somebody
yeah you know you don't say i'm saying
[ __ ] whatever whatever
type of hope i'm dealing with that's
what kind of people you understand me
you have to adapt for the girl
yeah and how many girls do you have
right now [ __ ] five five yeah
and what nationality are these girls are
they african-american white
hispanic well mate is here
right now they're all african-american
right now but you know i'm in the
process of trying to i'm putting you in
a new state because
really you know black holes they ain't
pretty smooth pretty cool
pay too slow for me so right now the
only thing a black hole would do for me
and show me where the white hole went
yeah you want some white girls ain't
what i want to get anything i want i'm
going to get some white girl
yeah because [ __ ] i'm going to have to
get them but they won't be here to get
me
and you have sex with your girls part of
me do you have sex with your girls
[ __ ] i've had before but i'm gonna tell
you this up
it's like it won't be no
sex for pleasure none of that i really
be
like you know seeing what i'm dealing
with because you know
you no no pleasure i don't even you know
it's a wham-bam thank you ma'am you know
are drugs a part of your life or the
girls that work for you
i mean well you know to be honest you
know i don't want to just
speak on their you know personal life
but
it's like you know drills is
is in the world so you know it's how it
goes you just gotta
you know you gotta be skeptical and deal
with everything it's gotta be hard for a
girl to do this kind of work
without being drunk or high or something
right well no
because i'm seeing this here it's like
the drugs
you know i'm saying i'm saying drugs
more like a mind thing
so what they're being said um
the girls they don't just necessarily
have drugs the drugs doesn't won't
you know say what i'm saying because
they want some drugs they don't mean
they don't get it but
you know most likely i treat my whole
good but i'm gonna say this here
you know like if they need some
uh not need if they want some drills if
i feel like they deserve
something then i might you know make a
call to make it happen but
i don't you know that's all i just know
some folks that know some folks they
just
don't you know i don't deal with nothing
you know what i'm saying
so now the game has changed a lot since
you were young right
yeah the laws the penalties are stricter
now right
probably the penalties are more extreme
for you guys now
yes you know it's it's like
really the social media [ __ ] you know he
really can't
so you know really you know
pimping just you know it's really
criminally designed but a pimp saying a
whole design
they're going to pay the same so that
business is just you know [ __ ]
know how to move and that's how you need
to move
so are you nice to your girls do you
treat them well
i mean how do you how do you greet them
when you see them
[ __ ] top of the morning [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you know what today brian
slow feet don't eat you hit them slip on
some heels and make me some mobiles
[ __ ]
have you done any prison time
um what was that for
seven drugs
what kind of girls do you look for this
kind of work is not for every girl
right well they go like this
i don't look for no kind you understand
what i'm saying
and all i can tell you is a mother needs
to look for me
you know i'm from high
so you know so the girl gives you how
much of the money
you know that they're going to give me
all the money if you want to ask a
question yeah how much i get them
how much do you give them yeah again
what they need you need to get some eat
nice clothes you know outfit hurt them
and all that you know
i'll take all the servers but i'll run
all the money
and what do they get in return for
giving you all the money
well you're getting return yeah what do
you provide
yeah security guy you know what i'm
saying and
most of all me you know what i'm saying
so
you know it costs it costs to even be
around me
you know this year ain't fake i ain't
free
does a girl need to be attracted to you
or like you
sure i've heard that from a lot of guys
you know i don't even know it's just
like this right here
when you're a pimp you know what i'm
saying you know you don't go
look around for who you like and
you think she's cute i want her you
don't go like that when you're a pimp
you like who like you
what do you think the the core of the
pimp and prostitute relationship is
is the girl trying to recreate the
childhood relationship you had with her
dad
yeah i don't know what i don't know what
they really be looking for but whatever
they're looking for it's all inside of
her
you're saying yeah
you've done this a long time what's
what's the craziest thing you've seen
out there on the street
the tricks must be nuts you said with a
chick
the tricks must have crazy behavior
right yeah
you know one thing about it you know a
chicken a good sense you know
what i'm saying so you know don't you
never be surprised what the trigger do
you know so i've seen a whole lot of
[ __ ] my i would never be surprised with
a trigger do a trigger do
anything you understand me okay
and the girls who work for you are they
sometimes hustling stealing
stuff like that yeah they're just
getting the tricks watched
right if they if the [ __ ] if they if
they
don't like if you don't do it i say you
don't like me you like somebody else
yeah so you know i give them up for the
order and you ain't got you know either
you're gonna follow
or you're not
what's more important to you love or
money
[Music]
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years of doing this
never trust a hoe
ain't gonna tell you what a whole won't
do [ __ ]
a whole do anything [ __ ] do you have
kids
yeah yeah 14 kids ten boys and four
girls
are you raising them of course i'm not
all they live
do you have any boys following in dad's
footsteps
yes i do and it's not and i'm i'm a pimp
[ __ ]
you know i i can't worry i do everything
i need to do
because i'm raising my kids i'm trying
to teach them how to be young men
so they see me get them go to work every
day they know how bills are getting paid
you don't know about the stuff i'm gonna
say you understand what i'm saying
do you have any regrets in your life
yeah i got some regrets
i shouldn't trust the last though you
don't see me
[ __ ]
all right all right ap thank you so much
for sharing your story all right
best of luck out there
when you walk in the door what do you
say to your girls well what do you know
i said
[ __ ] hold your breath and break
yourself that whole